quand j' j'ai envie de quelque chose ou
que ce soit dans la vie personnelle ou
dans la vie professionnelle je suis
Allis jusqu'au bout bonsoir Rachida Dati
merci d'être ici ce soir alors je vous
appelle Rachida Dati parce que en
général on vous appelle d'ailleurs comme
cela et rarement madame la ministre si
dans certaines circonstances on madame
on m'appelle madame la ministre puis
dans d'autres où on m'appelle par par
mon prénom mais c'est pas désagréable
qu'est-ce que vous préférez en fonction
des circonstances il ce soir vous
m'appelez comme vous le souhaitez c'est
la Rachida intime qu'on a envie
d'entendre ce soir alors Rachida ça veut
dire bien guidé c'est ça la traduction
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit d'ailleurs je
l'ai appris très tard mon prénom voulait
dire ce cel parce que c'est vrai que nos
prénoms pour l'essentiel dans la famille
sont indiqu à chaque fois quelques
vertus ou et mais vous ne parlez pas
arabe je ne le lis pas et je ne l'écris
pas mais je parle je parle arabe
dialectal voilà et donc est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'être bien guidé just
justement je m'en suis pas trop mal
sorti jusqu'à maintenant ou c'est un
joli parcours he même si vous connaissez
des turbulences c'est un beau parcours
je va pas me plaindre certaines choses
qui ont été dites par vos proches vous
ont étonné moi je suis je suis assez
touchée et assez ému d'entendre mon père
parler parce qu' d'abord il est très
pique et je crois que je sais pas s'il
aurait dit les mêmes choses au moment où
j'ai été nommé ministre aujourd'hui il a
un petit peu plus de recul parce qu'il y
a certains commentaires ou peut-être des
observations pour ne pas dire des
critiques qui forcément l'atteignent
mais dont il ne me parle pas et dont il
m'a jamais parlé parce que là
effectivement on a le sentiment que les
critiques finalement l'atteignent plus
et dépassent la fierté qu'il a
effectivement de cette nomination et de
cette fonction aujourd'hui quoi il a une
réelle fierté à ce que je sois ministre
de la justice de ce
pays je l'ai toujours dit parce que faut
pas oublier que il est arrivé en fin 63
64 en France dans un pays qu'il ne
connaissait absolument pas coupé de tout
toutes ses racines de sa famille il
arrivve avec maman et et c'est vrai que
finalement 40 ans plus tard sa fille le
ministre de la Justice de de ce pays
qu'il a qu'il a accueilli donc pour lui
bien sûr que c'est une véritable fierté
et parfois quand il entend certains
commentaires pas forcément agréable il
se reconnaît pas dans dans l'éducation
qu'il a pu me donner il reconnaît pas
non plus la fille qui l'a vu au
quotidien qu'est-ce qu'il vous a dit
d'ailleurs lorsque vous avez été nommé
il y a 2 ans bientôt il a été très ému
il a pensé à maman en disant qu'il
regrettait qu'elle ne soit pas là pour
ce moment-l j'imagine que vous aussi
oui ça c'est vraiment le point le plus
fragile chez vous c'est c'est ma plus
grande force d'avoir eu la M que j'ai eu
et en même temps le plus grand manque
c'est mon plus grand chagrin moi j'ai
intégré la mort dans la vie au moment du
décès de
maman tant qu'elle était là j'avais
jamais
intégré si la mort existait mais pas à
ce point et c'est vrai que ensuite le
regard que je portais sur mon père a
changé parce qu'il intégrait aussi cette
éventuelle disparition donc je me sens
je me sens encore plus de devoirs
vis-à-vis de lui alors moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a une très très
grande différence d'ailleurs entre la
Rachida Dati publique et la personne
privée est-ce que vous vous en rendez
compte vous entre peut-être l'image que
on a de vous est ce que vous êtes
réellement c'est ce que dit très bien
d'ailleurs mon ami Valérie Pinau
valencienne c'est qu'à un moment donné
vous vous êtes dépassé c'est c'est vrai
je reconnais sans doute il y a-t-il eu
des erreurs dans cette exposition mais à
un moment donné vous êtes dépassé et
comme vous au départ vous vous essayez
de corriger vous essayez de d'expliquer
et puis à un moment donné vous êtes un
peu dépassé donc vous mettez un peu en
retrait vous reconnaissez plus ni dans
les images ni dans les propos qu'on peut
vous prêter est-ce que maintenant avec
le recul hein puisque vous allez bientôt
quittter le le ministère vous dites je
me suis trop exposé les robes j'aurais
dû faire un peu plus attention moi il y
a une chose sur lequelle j'ai pas voulu
renoncer c'est à ma féminité j'étais
comme ça avant et je continuerai à être
comme ça même après le
gouvernement mais aucun renoncement ù il
y a la féminité ensuite qu'on on dis du
goût du luxe Jef quand vous avez des
dîners d'État et qu'on vous dit c'est
une Rob longue obligatoire vous vous
habillez en fonction du dîner ou ou de
de la manifestation c'est important je
crois qu'il faut aussi faire honneur à
sa fonction et à son pays votre sœur et
Jacques Atalie d'ailleurs disent
finalement elle est très attaquée parce
que c'est une femme et surtout surtout
parce qu'elle a montré son ambition et
qu'en France quand on ne vient pas d'un
milieu privilégié qu'on est ambitieux on
se fait traiter de parvenu oui c'est
comme l'ambition c'est pas un vilam mot
je crois que quand vous commencez un
parcours professionnel ou même quand
vous êtes à l'école vous avez l'ambition
de réussir vous avez l'ambition de vous
en sortir euh ce qui peut être gênant
c'est simplement si au bout d'un moment
c'est récurrent insistant persistant on
peut imaginer que que tout ça est fait
avec un objectif précis c'est de nuire à
votre pas à votre image à ce que vous
êtes et donc à votre personne mais
est-ce que sincèrement vous avez été
atteinte parce que vous semblez comme ça
très forte et on voit quand même vos
amis dire elle s'en est pris quand même
un peu plein la figure quand vous
acceptez une responsabilité politique et
de surcroix publique
mais ce qui peut vous faire de la
peine c'est l'impact que ça ça cré sur
vos proches sur votre entourage même
personnel et puis un peu plus largement
sur votre famille bien sûr le plusé
finalement votre famille il les attaque
un peu sur attaque sur la légèreté sur
finalement la futilité sur
l'incompétence ça ça peut heurter et
vous qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
heurter moi c'est
moi je serz vous c'est plutôt de dire
qu'est-ce qui me motive encore plus
aujourd'hui non non non mais ma question
je la réitère non mais c'est qu'est-ce
qui vous a le plus fait mal dans ce qui
a été dit bah ça me motive encore plus
pour ne pas pour ne pas renoncer à
lutter contre ces conservatisme alors
c'est un moment clé dans votre vie en 2
ans nomé garde des
saau maman a plus de 40 ans pour la
première fois et maintenant parti pour
les européennes c'est dans
m du 7è arrondissement j'oubliais
évidemment c'est un moment fort
sentiment que c'est allé vite trop vite
c'est sûr que ça fait beaucoup de choses
en très peu de temps mais ça ne me
déplaît pas il faut pas oublier que j'ai
eu un enfant quand même ce qui c'est
plus important que le reste ah pour moi
c'est extrême c'est fondamental pour moi
c'était important de d'avoir un enfant
puis la vie parfois vous vous indique
que c'est pas possible c'est difficile
pens ne pas en avoir oui donc pour moi
c'est
arrivé vraiment providentielle c'était
voulu c'est un enfant désiré entièrement
désiré mais qui était pas attendu mais
donc une surprise c'est ça que voulais
dire plus c'était une heureuse
[Rires]
surprise et ça a transformé votre vie
oui puis à la fois ça le transforme sauf
que si je suis totalement
sincère quand je la regarde je tous les
jours parfois je réalise pas que que
j'ai eu cette enfant vous voyez la vie
différemment puis vous avez moins
d'obsession je suis moins obsessionnelle
sur certaines choses sur lesqueles vous
allez moins penser à Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est ça c'est pas une obsession c'est
pas une obsession non c'est quand même
un point d'ancrage c'est pas une
obsession ah
vous en parlez beaucoup référent c'est
un référent c'est un référent mais j'en
parle beaucoup pourquoi par d'abord
c'est le chef de l'État il est normal
que quand même je défende avec
conviction les responsabilités que nous
ont confié les français pour revenir à à
la maternité quand même ça été ça a été
difficile non de vivre une grossesse au
moment enfin où il y avait quand même
beaucoup de manifestations ça d être un
moment difficile pour vous non on peut
rêver mieux non comme grossesse on peut
toujours rêver mieux moi j'aurais rêvé
mieux de peut-être d'avoir plusieurs
enfants d'avoir donc on peut toujours
avé mieux mais à la fois c'est difficile
ce que vous me demandez parce que je
suis jamais plainte de manière générale
donc c'est difficile j'ai l'impression
presque ça serait indécent de vous dire
c'est difficile pas difficile par
rapport par rapport aux femmes en
général bien sûr moi c'est vrai que j'ai
une grossesse qui s'est quand même
plutôt bien passé mais comment vous avez
fait d'ailleurs ça a créé une polémique
hein par rapport au droit des mamans à
rester chez elles et tout à être quand
même sur pied un conseil des ministres 5
jours après avoir accouché sous
césarienne je crois oui vous êtes fait
d'acier trempé j'aime la vie et pour moi
c'est cette naissance a transcendé
tellement de choses je dis pas je
c'était pas c'était pas pour fanfaroné
pas du
tout vous pouvez bien imaginer qu'avec
la vie que j'ai eu je suis pas dans la
performance j'ai rien à prouver si
j'avais été fatiguée ou si j'aurais pas
pu être debout je serais pas venu j'
mais à la fois je dis pas que j'ai pas
été fatigué et puis j'ai l'âge j'ai pas
20 ans hein vous avez compris la
polémique ça a déclenché le fait que
vous reveniez travailler justement 5
jours après avoir accouché vous la
comprenez d'abord je suis garde des
saous je suis ministre de la justice
c'est pas un travail comme un autre euh
j'ai aussi plus de facilité je suis
aussi très entourée moi je vois ma fille
si si demain j'ai une difficulté j'ai
toujours une sœur j'ai quelqu'un j'ai
voilà donc c'est quand même une chance
et c'est pas et il faut se battre moi je
pense parce que le congé maternité c'est
un acquis social c'est vrai il faut pas
le remettre en cause c'est ce que je
voulais vous demander c'est pas une de
REM en cause simplement le combat des
femmes aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles aient
le libre choix le libre choix de vouloir
revenir travailler ou de ne pas
travailler de de pouvoir se reposer ou
de ne pas se reposer il faut qu' le
combat c'est pour le libre choix c'est
pas de remettre en cause un acqui social
alors votre père justement com comment
votre père a réagi à la naissance de la
petite Zora donc le fait que sa fille
est un
enfant sans être marié c'est à Lui qu'
faut demander ah mais on lui a demander
justement vous ne croyez pas si bien
dire com je sais pas ce qu'il a pu vous
répondre vous qu'est-ce qu'il vous a dit
rien rien il ne vous a rien dit il a été
silencieux sur le sujet je pense que au
fond lui-même il aurait préféré que ce
soit un peu plus conventionnel peut-être
que c'est vrai sans doute que je sois
marié vous aimeriez être marié ça jamais
été quelque chose qui m'a vraiment
euh très attiré mais bon ça jamais été
pour moi une fixation pour prendre votre
expression vous l' retenu pourquoi tant
de mystères quand même non mais autour
du autour du père de
zura mais il est pas surpris parce qu'il
considère
que je suis libre bien entendu bien
entendu j'ai pas souhaité le faire et et
c'est un moyen de respecter le père de
ma fille respecter ma fille et me
respecter au passage mais est-ce que
vous le ferez un jour puisque vous
l'avez présenté à votre père donc oui
mais c'est pas c'est pas comme ça que ça
se conçoit c'est vous savez les vies
personnelles la vie personnelle je crois
que vous pouvez pas me démentir c'est
toujours très fragile c'est vrai
donc et donc quand en plus si vous vous
l'exposez il y a un risque il y a un
risque de d'accroître ou d'accentuer
cette fragilité moi j'ai besoin de de
cette vie personnelle qui tous les jours
me permet aussi bah d'aimer la vie de
continuer à l'affronter d'être motivé de
continuer mes engagements al ce soir je
ne vais pas vous n'êtes pas là pour
donner le nom du père de Zora ce que je
voudrais savoir enche je ne lâche rien
en tout cas vous ne l'avez pas fait pour
attiser une nouvelle curiosité et créer
un feuilleton médiatique comme ça comme
les mauvaises langues on pu le dire Oui
puis j'ai fait exprès d'être enceinte
aussi
tiens passage ça pe comment vous avez
d'ailleurs vous réagi à toutes ces
rumeurs c'est pas c'est pas les Français
c'est pas la France qui qui est
grossière finalement c'est certains
c'est un petit
microcosme qui se croit
autorisé B je trouve que finalement
c'est c'est ce microcosme là qui est
peut-être un petit peu plus grossier
voilà ils auraient beaucoup à apprendre
des Français et de la France tel qu'elle
est et l'équilibre vient plutôt de de la
famille l'équilibre vient de cet ancrage
et d'avoir une famille qui est
effectivement très solide mais
heureusement que j'ai cet ancrage
heureusement j'ai beaucoup oup de neè
aussi mais oui pour lesqueles vous êtes
très très importante oui moi je les aime
tellement c'est vrai et c'est pour ça
que quand ma fille est né j'ai dit bah
moi aussi je
contribue c'est votre contribution c'est
c'est ils sont pas tous là oui ce n'est
qu'une petite partie vous êtes quand
même comme le second chef de famille
mais c'est pas du tout pour pour être là
en disant je sais tout tout le monde et
je vaux faire à votre place mais moi
j'avais une préoccupation d'abord ce que
dit mon frère est vrai euh mes parents
ont tout donné donc on se devait aussi
de ne pas les décevoir alors après c'est
comme dans toutes les familles il y a
des difficultés nous on a eu des
difficultés dans notre famille on a eu
des difficultés avec certains de mes
frères en particulier il y a de vraies
difficultés alors après comment on fait
bah il faut il faut accepter c'est vrai
que c'est difficile mon père l'a très
mal vécu parce qu'il ne comprenait pas
pourquoi certains et ça sortait moins
sortait moins bien
quand AZ votream qui est triste paril a
unème quand votre père sait plus faire
face à uneé et vous dites attendez je
vais m'occuper de tout pourquoi par que
moi je voulais pas qu'il soit triste
moi justement c'est vous qui vous êtes
retrouvé on voit bien en plus que vos
frères et sœurs disent voilà c'est elle
qui a pris en charge mais il y a très
longtemps en fait pratiquement depuis
depuis
toujours parce que j'estimais que
j'avais tellement plus de chance que la
plupart d'entre eux mais comment vous
saviez déjà adolescente c'est ça qui et
parce que d'abord je cherchais du
travail j'ai été je vous dis j'ai
commencé à vendre à travailler j'avais
14 ans à 16 ans j'ai été animatrice
ensuite j'ai été caissière j'ai été
soignante et c'est vrai que j'ai
travaillé très tôt tout le temps et à la
fois j'ai c'est vrai que j'ai donné
satisfaction dans les dans les activités
professionnel donc je me disais et puis
j'arrivais parce que vous étiez assez
brillante en tout c'est ça et puis comme
l'école se passait bien donc je me
disais j'ai quand même un peu plus de
chance et de facilité peut-être queun de
mes frères qui qui était beaucoup plus
fragile c'est comme si vous sentiez en
vous quelque chose de plus fort qui
allit vous portez plus loin d'où ça
vient ça parce que à chaque fois que
j'ai j'ai j'ai souhaité quelque chose ou
je suis battu pour avoir quelque chose
c'est vrai que je l'ai obtenu ça para
oui ça paraît un
peu c'est c'est même presque gênant et
c'est vrai que je me disais j'ai quand
même quelques facilités
[Musique]
je mais en fait c'est c'est ça votre
audace c'est d'avoir demandé les choses
moi j'ai toujours été très clair je n'y
allais pas par quatre chemin moi quand
je rencontrais quelqu'un je disais voilà
je vais travailler pour vous à tel
endroit où je veux faire ça pour vous
oui ou non est-ce que je je pensais que
je pourrais obtenir ça mais j'ai jamais
été ambigu moi il y a pas eu d'équivoque
ou d'ambigué j'imagine qu'il y avait une
conviction Jacques Atali il y a 20 ans
vous l'avez rencontré comme ça je crois
comme Albain Chalandon et jeanl la
garder et d'autres c'était vous
demandiez les choses oui moi je machin
donc quand je le rencontre je dis voilà
moi je j'aimerais vous rencontrer parce
que j'aimerais vous MZ à trouver un
stage en entreprise mais au début m'a
dit oui prenez contact avec mon j'ai dis
non mais dites-moi oui ou non est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour qu'on on se voit
ou pas donc s'il m'avait dit non bon
voilà je vais rien à perdre vous n'avez
jamais d'ailleurs été freiné non jamais
eu peur du regard des autres non parce
que même si ça pouvait parfois être
désagréable il que moi qui savait
ouais ça portait pas il y avait pas de
grandes conséquences he puis comme
personne me connaissait même si c'était
un nom public ça me gênait absolument
pas vousz reçu d'ailleurs desou bien sûr
lesquels voilà on disait non c'est pas
possible
non c'est pas pour vous non c'est trop
prétentieux c'est pas de votre niveau
voilà je l'ai entendu mais ça fait
partie des choses de la vie sinon ça
sera trop simple oui ça veut dire que
quand on veut avancer quand on veut
justement s'en sortir de toute façon on
fonce voilà on a on a rien à perdre
c'est ça que vous êtes en train de dire
ça a marché pour moi voilà il fallait
réussir pour vous dans ce que j'entends
et pour votre famille ce n'est pas
qu'une réussite personnelle puis pour
aussi on habitait je rappelle la
première cité mon habité elle s'appelait
La Cité de la liberté et euh qui était
rue de la Liberté je me souviens parce
que c'était vrai quartier populaire et
puis moi je trouve enfin quand j'ai
commencé un peu évoluer changer de
milieu Mo j'ai l'impression que ça
gratifiait tout le monde moi je me
souviens les voisines les amis de maman
disantent c'est formidable mais tiens
Rachida elle a réussi à connaître un tel
et donc elle a réussi à obtenir cet
emploi elle peut peut-être nous aider
d'ailleurs pour N enfants et donc c'est
comme moi je là je me sentais aussi une
responsabilité vis-à-vis du
voisinage parce que tout le monde était
content et moi je le vois à chaque fois
que j'ai eu une progression à chaque
fois tout le monde était content quand
je deviens porte-parole de Nicolas
Sarkozi tout le monde était pour Nicolas
Sarkozi ils ont fait campagne avec nous
tout le monde faisait campagne al mais
je même ce qui n'était pas pour Sarko
tout le monde était convaincu
hein vous demandz beaucoup de choses
aussi non détrompez-vous pas tant que ça
pas tant que ça on vous demande alors
c'est sûr que on vous demande de les
aider parce que parfois on comprend pas
des situations
mais faut pas croire les gens sont
beaucoup plus respectueux que ça et ils
sont beaucoup plus honorés que cela
alors vous avez reçu quand même et moi
c'est ce qui m'a frappé vous étiez avec
votre sœur Malica les les deux seules
filles d'ouvriers musulmanes dans une
école catholique privée votre père c'est
votre père qui avait construit c'est
c'est très joli hein cette école des
travaux de construction dans cette école
qui s'appelait le devoir et euh le
devoir la
liberté tout y est he cette école
d'abord qui était une école de fille et
et mon père
disait c'est une école religieuse ça va
vous apprendre le bien et le mal ça vous
fera pas de mal et euh et pu c'est est
très ouvert quand même aussi mais c'est
un homme de foi oui oui c'est ça et le
catholicisme mais au-delà des justement
des cvages religieux mais il considit
que la foi voilà on respecte les
croyants et gens qu' on la foi vous
senti tirailler ou plutôt un pont jeté
entre deux cultures c'est ça que je
voudrais savoir parce que ça s'est
jamais posé en ces termes jamais c'est
dire que mes parents sont arrivés en
France ils ont eu des enfants leurs
enfants étaient français mon père a
appris à lire écrire avec nous et maman
elle était totalement unalphabète
finalement elle a jamais appris ni à
lire ni à écrire ça pas beaucoup
intéressé et l'important la culture
l'éducation oui et pas de barrière parce
que le fait d'être dans un collège privé
aucune barrière nulle part ni sociale ni
culturelle pas de barrière moi c'est
très tard que je me suis rendu compte
que le milieu social pouvait générer une
fracture notamment dans l'ambition dans
la promotion ou dans l'accession à
certains emplois mais aucun moment moi
je suis rendu compte enfant ou
adolescent je me disis bon bah si on
travaille on peut y arriver et mon père
nous disait toujours euh faut pas vous
laisser me dites pas parce que son père
il est médecin que il arrive mieux parce
que son père est médecin je vous
préviens je suis je suis pas d'accord
hein parce que l'intelligence c'est pas
lié au statut et donc du coup nous très
vite on a dit il a raison c'est pour ça
aussi voilà vous avez pu franchir aussi
rapidement a parce que j'avais pas de
complexe par rapport à par rapport à ça
j'estimais que j'étais française pas de
blocage non n'avz jamais souffert de de
xénophobie de racisme non mais alors
encore une fois ce qui ce qui ce qui
permet de masquer ça ou de sauver ça ou
de pas s'en rendre compte j'étais un peu
turbulente et et parfois un peu sans
doute agaçante donc
si vous êtes toujours visibleblement
pour certains donc si si on pouvit être
désagréable avec moi moi je disais bon
c'est normal faut dire aussi parce que
parfois je dépasse un peu les bordnes
mais j'ai jamais mis ça sur le compte
d'autre chose que sur le tempérament
vous le dites maintenant parce que toute
façon non parce que je le dis maintenant
parce que je me rends compte que les
blocages sont pas là où on croit
c'est-à-dire pour être plus explicite
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire de dire
oh mais pas tout de suite mais c'est pas
pour toi moi je vois même dans le
regard et mais beaucoup plus tardivement
et heureusement je l'ai pas perçu avant
parce que peut-être que ça m'aurait
découragé peut-être ouais c'est ce que
je voulais vous demander mais comme je
l'ai pas perçu avant j'ai estimis que
pratiquement ça n'existait pas moi je
trouve que dans dans notre pays dans moi
j'aime tellement la France que il y a
pas de détermin
et peut-être qu'aujourd'hui quand on
vous subissez quelques commentaires ou
des observations c'est qu'on considère
que qui est un déterministe ça voudrait
dire qu'on n pas le droit c'est ce que
disait jacquali parvenu non justement on
est dans une démocratie dans une
République et le mérite doit êtreonnu
vous avz travaillé vous devez être
cononnu et c'est pas réservé qu'à
certains donc femme moderne femme
d'aujourd'hui femme indépendante libre
et en même temps attaché quand même à la
tradition voire soumise à la tradition
c'est attaché à ma famille c'est c'est
plutôt une valeur qu'une tradition parce
que c'est ce qui est justement
intéressant chez vous c'est que vous
êtes une femme de paradoxe lorsque vous
avez accepté de vous marier il y a
maintenant il y a combien de temps vous
Z 1992 92 voilà lorsque vous avez
accepté ce mariage qui vous a été
proposé non pas forcé mais qu'est-ce
qu'on va dire arrangé vous l'avez fait
pour faire plaisir à vos
parents c'est plus compliqué que ça
c'est plus compliqué que ça c'est vrai
que je suis partie à 20 ans je 21 ans je
rencontre Alba Chalon qui garde des
sauts ma vie change la vie matérielle
change le quotidien de mes parents
change dans un endroit où o il y avait
de grandes difficultés
et alors que j'étais sur trois emplois
en même temps quatre emplois en même
temps c'est incroyable vous avez fait à
ce momentl je travaillais j'étais en
contrat à duré indéterminé dans une
entreprise mais je travaillais le samedi
dimanche en plus je donnais des coups
j'avais plusieurs activités et à un
moment
donné là où habitaent mes parents il y
avait un peu pas de candiraton mais il y
avait une difficulté à expliquer
justement ce ce parcours un peu un peu
rapide un peu fulgurant de ma part donc
et donc j'ai accepté j'ai accepté
de finalement une convention al donc
c'était quand même important le
candiraton ça ne m'a pas fait souffrir
mais je ne voulais pas que mes parents
mon entourage en souffre
ou souffre de quelques commentaires donc
j'ai accepté je me disais moi je m'en
sortirai toujours voilà c'est incroyable
ça ça revient je m'en sortirai toujours
mais c'est pour leur faire plaisir mais
alors de toute façon vous l'avez annulé
ce mariage en plus il est annulé oui
j'ai pas d'autres commentaires à faire
là-dessus c'est une période de ma vie
qui que vous préférez oublier mais c'est
ce qui a marqué beaucoup les uns et les
autres jacat al qu'on a interviewé aussi
qui avait été très marqué par C parce
que je lui beaucoup au moment où j'ai
souhaité l'annulation de ce mariage et
jamais vous ne vous appitoyez sur
vous-même il y a pas lieu c'est une
partie de ma vie que j'ai géré comme
d'autres parties de ma vie c'était une
difficulté comme j'ai pu gérer d'autres
difficultés mais c'est pas oh là là
c'est terrible c'est horrible et j'en ai
été anéanti pas du tout non mais non
mais on voit bien moi je suis allé
jusqu'au bout de quand j'ai vu g envie
de quelque chose ou que ce soit dans la
vie personnelle ou dans la vie
professionnelle je suis allé jusqu'au
bout voilà euh si ça finit bien tant
mieux ça finit moins bien j'aurais
essayé voilà mais je vais jusqu'au bout
des choses qu'est-ce que vous attendez
vous d'un homme j'imagine que un homme
autoritaire c'est bizarre normalement
devrait vous faire peur quand on prend
les hommes qui vous fascine pour revenir
en politique Nicolas Sarkozi sont plutôt
des hommes à poigne
oui des hommes d'autorité puis pas de
double langage pas de truc à peu près
voilà mais c'est vrai donc plutôt à
l'image de votre père dans le euh plutôt
pas à l'image de l'autoritarisme si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire il faut
davantage expliquer il est très
autoritaire et ce côté j'ai toujours
raison est un petit peu parfois
j'aimerais pas le retrouver forcément
dans ma vie donc que
lui veuille toujours avoir raison c'est
normal c'est mon père pour le reste non
alors quel serait votre rêve le le plus
incroyable pour le futur j'en sais rien
alors là vous prenez de courses j'en
sais rien Rachida Dati dans 10 ans envie
de continuer en politique en tout cas
ouis et avec euh tout ce que je vous ai
dit pendant cette émission me motive
encore plus pour
euh dire que on va pas se débarrasser de
moi comme ça il y a encore ça c'est dit
je crois qu'on je crois qu'on on
commençait à le comprendre ça veut dire
que vous êtes piqué au virus de de la
politique sinon vous ne seriez pas parti
pour les Européens vous seriez reparti
dans un oui dans le privé et je crois
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de combat à
mener vous ne sortez pas amer de cette
expérience
non en c'est c'est pas le mot qui qui me
viendrait qu'est-ce que vous diriez
justement moi ça a été mais ça a été une
immense chance et un immense honneur que
que d'être garde des saau enfin je sais
pas si on se rend compte je vais quand
même pas sortir
amer c'est moi je trouve que d'être
ministre de la Justice de la France mais
quel vous pourrait être l'amertume
pourrait se loger l'amertume mais vous
pourriez être un peu amer parce que vous
avez quand même app tout le programme
vous êtes allé jusqu'au bout ça personne
làdessus vous avez c'était même si vous
êtes passé en force vous y êtes allés et
puis finalement Nicolas Sarko moi je ne
suis pas propriétaire du ministère de la
Justice oui c'est vrai je suis garde des
saut il est président de la République
tout d'abord je lui dois tout puis c'est
lui qui m'a nommé garde des saau je
quand même pas dire que finalement il
m'a maltraité ça serait quand même le
comble mais devais aussi tout à à
Cécilia Sarkozi son exp je lui dois
beaucoup et je je n'ai jamais renié ce
qu'elle a apporté dans ma vie et je lui
dois beaucoup qu'est-ce que vous avez
appris justement de cette expérience moi
ça ça m'intéresse qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
que vous vous dites aujourd'hui moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est pas de dire c'est
un succès personnel c'est que dans
quelques mois ou dans quelques années on
puisse
dire heureusement que la justice a été
réformée elle m'a mieux protégé on dit
oui elle ne connaissait pas les codes si
je connaissais justement je les
connaissais trop bien et c'est je pense
aussi ce qui a pu aussi en déranger
certains mais moi j'estime que la France
n'appartient pas qu'à certains dire que
on réforme pas la justice pour une une
corporation ou pour un corps et vos
espérances vos espoirs à titre privé ben
que je puisse être je puisse continuer à
être heureuse avec un bonheur qui est
celui de ma fille et oui voilà c'est
c'est quand même ça
non aussi l'avenir aussi c'est aussi ça
non non c'est a a ça et maintenant c'est
beaucoup avec ça merci beaucoup Rachid
adati m'avoir accordé cet entretien
d'ailleurs je voulais vous demander
pourquoi vous aviez accepté de parler ce
soir je trouve que votre émission n'est
pas
intrusive c'est pas familier et puis à
la fois je trouve que en tant que
responsable public c'est aussi pas
inintéressant pour les Français de voir
de quoi vous êtes fait parce que parfois
je je pense que il y a une volonté de de
biaiser ou caricaturer donc c'est bien
aussi de faire quelques mises au point
de temps en temps merci beaucoup merci
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Inna
Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche